a perfect end to a painful week for
boris johnson
he married carrie simons in secret with
a small covert compliance ceremony
surrounded by close family and friends
it happened here at westminster
cathedral the couple's local catholic
church
and the largest in the uk a surprise for
parishioners
it's lovely lovely lovely for here he
got married yesterday now at church
oh lovely him getting married
it's good for him it settles him down
he's got someone to go home to every day
i just think might also be good for his
temperament
although he's been married twice before
neither of the pm's previous weddings
were catholic meaning this one was
allowed their son was baptized here
carries a practicing catholic and so
every catholic has a right to get
married in their local parish
they go to the priest the priest has to
determine whether they're free to marry
so they look at boris johnson's previous
marriages and that they're not
recognized as catholic marriages in the
catholic church
and so they have they're free to get
married as they have been was it nice
today boris johnson's sister was saying
nothing as the messages of
congratulations began
i want to congratulate the prime
minister and carrie simmons
on tying the knot figures from across
the political spectrum have wished the
couple well
although former labour front venture
john trickett tweeted
that boris johnson's secret wedding was
a good way to bury this week's bad news
before divorcing second wife marina
wheeler boris johnson started dating
carrie simons a former
conservative press officer and special
adviser within months of moving into
number 10 they became engaged
and their son wilfred was born last
april
one of the prime minister's biographers
argues a surprise wedding
is typical one of the features of boris
johnson's unpredictable unconventional
life is he likes a surprise he likes to
take
people by shock that has been one of his
great qualities he would be delighted in
surprising those who thought he would
never marry
carrie simmons and in exactly the same
way
he's going to surprise us more in the
weeks and months ahead
the question is always whether the
surprise is for the benefit of the
country or not
after yesterday's ceremony a small
reception was held in the downing street
garden
with bunting lanterns and a barefoot
bride
the open-sided marquis a teepee and a
ring of hay bales were still visible
today
it's not clear whether this building has
been the venue for a wedding reception
ever before
but boris johnson is the first prime
minister to marry in office
since lord liverpool in 1822 199 years
ago
sources have though confirmed carrie
simons will take
her new husband's surname she'll now be
known as carrie johnson
the celebrations though are far from
over mr and mrs johnson will host a
larger wedding celebration
and have their honeymoon next summer